Y allá
[Música]
O
reto es ir a donde nadie va, ahí está la abuela
ya es una campaña aquí no es una
distribución de juguetes simplemente
es una fiesta de navidad es tomar un momento
de alegría por la vida de estos niños
de estas comunidades con ya realidad
durante el año es tan duro y
[Aplausos]
Y allá
Ey
[Música]
Hola Paulinho de Santa Claus vamos podemos
cambiar el mundo pero podemos hacer uno
niño sonríe esta navidad que esta A
La misión de los amigos de Santa iré y
comunidad ribereña donde no hay
nadie te lleve paso amor y un
juguete para niños en el medio
de esta pandemia estamos aquí donde
muchos papas se fueron y otros se quedaron
que estamos juntos en esta misión 1
[Música]
Y allá